good morning thanks for being here
thanks for your patience we had a bit of
difficulty setting up like the life
system for a demo later in this
presentation
my name is Wesley and today I'm going to
give presentation about how to lower the
barrier for monitoring your ml systems
actually before we start let's start
with the question
a few things monitoring your ml models
is important
oh
that's a lot of you that's probably also
why you're here because you're
interested in it then the second
question who of you has ever implemented
some kind of ml monitoring before
all right nice quite a few hands a bit
less than everyone who is interested so
that's good then I have the Right
audience here
um before I continue let me Define
monitoring what I mean with monitoring
is any real-time information on how your
deployed machine learning model is
running in production like all that
information that it entails that's what
I mean with monitoring
but first let me introduce myself I'm
the leads machine learning engineer at
accelerated that means I have basically
two roles in the company first of all
I'm responsible for training a group of
Junior to Media or machine learning
engineers in a year with us to like
train them guide them help them out with
things that they encounter with their
clients and then secondly I'm also doing
consultancy products myself and
currently I'm a computer vision project
at Port of Rotterdam where I'm actually
right now implementing monitoring for
that project so that's actually nice
all right why monitoring
um regardless of how experienced you are
what kind of systems you build it is
guaranteed when we develop software that
there will problems that occur and it is
important to identify them early like if
the whole system shuts down you probably
know this quite quickly but if there's
like smaller bugs creeping into your
system you wanna like be able to
identify them and you want to diagnose
like why is this happening so that you
can solve it
um and then also if you're able to do
this then you're building up this big
database of how your model performed
like over the past months over the past
year so you can do all kinds of analysis
and performance reviews to also improve
the way your ml system is working
um so now that we know why we want to
monitor we can actually look at how we
can do monitoring and there's quite a
lot of tools out there in the open and
today I want to introduce two of them
they are Prometheus and grafana if you
have worked with this before
nice also quite a lot of you
so just to quickly introduce them
Prometheus I see this as like the back
end for like monitoring and alerting
it's used like a lot it's like this big
open source tool
um it's used for like traditional
software monitoring stuff it can be used
for ML stuff but it's maybe not that
popular yet
it works with a Time series database
with a smart data model that can save
data in an efficient way it works with
this HTTP pool model that means that if
you have your own model deployed as an
API somewhere you just need to expose
the metrics and then Prometheus will
scrape them and takes care of the rest
also they have this prompt ql querying
language where you can Aggregate and do
all kinds of queries on these on these
metrics
and secondly there's grafana which is
this dashboarding Tool uh probably a lot
of you have seen it or used it it's used
for interactive visualization it's kind
of this front end on on the monitoring
system and it has a nice integration
with Prometheus
uh it looks a bit like this if you spent
a lot of time building nice dashboards
um then let me introduce a scenario
so let's say we do a project and we're
trying to prediction for like this this
company doesn't really matter what
company we're trying to prediction when
like people will cancel their
subscription and you've built a simple
decision 3 model
on a specific data set to predict for
that and now you're ready to deploy it
and you deploy it using a fast API app
you expose the endpoints and you just
send a post request with your feature
values and you get back like either this
client is going to churn yes or no
within given time frame let's say a
month
you actually Implement two endpoints one
as a dummy with like a random endpoint
that just gives you some random
prediction back and you actually
Implement your model
uh on one of the other endpoints and
then besides that we have our two
interesting tools to do monitoring for
meteors and grafana and I'm going to run
through this scenario uh for my talk and
then in the end give you a live demo of
how it might work in practice
um to actually set us up locally I have
a bit of codes here on the slide it's
not about reading all the details of the
code I basically want to show you that
if you want to run this locally you can
do this by getting three parts in your
Docker compose
top Parts is your first API model it
runs on Port 5000 in my case then I have
for me to just use one of the available
versions that's on Docker Hub and I use
grafana so we have these three things by
the way the all the code that I'm
showing now is available on my GitHub
and you can actually run the same
project I'm showing here you can run it
also yourself on your own computer later
I'll provide the link at the end
um so this this whole system with this
fast API app
um
even though there's like this decision
tree model like
um deployed in there there's like
complex data flows but it's still an
application that needs to stay live and
needs to be monitored so we start out
from the point of this traditional
software monitoring and Google developed
this ID of the four golden signals
that's this Force these are the four
most important things to monitor if you
don't have anything in place already so
we monitor traffic like the number of
requests per second you get to your
system we we track latency like how long
does it take to handle such a requests
we want to monitor the errors like
either as like an absolute count or as
like a percentage of all your requests
and then lastly there's saturation which
I consider more like an infrastructure
monitoring thing so I'm not sure if I
want to include that in my application
you want to include it at your system
um
so let's actually do that let's make it
practical this is the end point that we
have it's a first API endpoint I assume
most of you have seen it's basically
this function that gets run when you hit
this endpoint
um
uh so this is the slash predict slash
model endpoint and what happens when you
put a post request here this piece of
code gets executed pretty simple we get
the features in from a Json with
powershets uh such that is an numpy
array or a pandas data frame or series
and then we make a prediction and return
this prediction
right here it doesn't have any
monitoring we want to add monitoring
then we do this we import from the
Prometheus clients we that's a python
client that's
is made to interact with Prometheus we
import two different uh objects the
counter object and the histogram object
to make a to basically model two of the
golden signals so the first one we see
here is a counter object it's called
request counts and it's
counts the total number of requests I
also put a label name on there so that
we can actually distinguish different
models like the random model and the
decision 3 models we have later down the
line
um for the latency I don't use a counter
because we're not just counting stuff
we're actually making this histogram
which is basically a counter of several
buckets uh here I just use the default
buckets
um it's basically just this uh object
that
is able to track like how long does it
take to fulfill this request
um now we're going to add them to our
first API endpoint so at the bottom you
see the request count
we call the model version and then we
increment it by one so each time this
function gets executed we increment this
metric by one and for the latency we
actually use The Decorator method
they're just multiple ways of doing this
we want to show both
um where we actually calculated time it
takes to execute this function and also
track this
then last step to actually make this a
reality is to
make these metrics available at your
fast API app like I said Prometheus
Works pool based so it's going to look
for metrics somewhere on your
application and then scrapes them in so
it's a responsibility of the fast API
app to show these metrics and we do this
at the slash metrics endpoint and we can
simply do that by which generates latest
function that we import from this
Prometheus client and then every so many
seconds it refreshes and like shows you
the latest metrics you can show it in
the demo how it works
all right
now we've looked at this traditional
setup like we added two of these golden
signals but we're here to talk about ml
monitoring so what is it that actually
makes this ml monitoring different well
there's a few things first of all we
have data flowing through this system
and there's all kinds of things that can
happen when we have data and we want to
be aware of it and I classify them in
two different categories there can be
problems with data availability maybe
like one of your data sources is offline
or you get it like in a wrong way why
and your model or your system is not
able to recognize your data
or we can have problems in the category
of quality that the data is actually
available but the distribution changed
completely
um maybe like the the unit of
measurement is different maybe there's
just changing things in society while
there's things off
um all kinds of things
and besides data the one component
that's different we also have this Black
Box model that is trained on a specific
data set which is basically sort of
snapshots of capturing these
relationships from the data to making
predictions and typically the
performance of these models Decay over
time depending on which use case and
what industry it's either decaying fast
or is decaying very slow but it's kind
of a given fact that these models tend
to perform worse over time like
um
all right so let's actually look at a
schematic setup of of this machine
learning model let's say from from the
left to the right we have two input data
sources one and two
from there we engineer the features they
get calculated in production system so
we then we end up at the features from
there the features are fed into the
model
and from there your model makes a
prediction
so we have this very simple setup with
data flowing from left to right if we
want to add monitoring First Step what
we can do is just measure the model
outputs so you can measure like
distributions of what gets predicted
whether it's like classification model
or regression type model or that kind of
things we can just capture whatever is
like the model is outputting to get to
answer the question like what is my
model doing because the whole idea of
this monitoring is like hey what is my
model doing
so that would be like the first priority
of monitoring
then secondly
to answer the question how well is my
model doing is it making the right
predictions we need to know the ground
truth so if we can if we're able to get
the ground fruit it would be good to
feed that back into the system and
actually monitor here the model
performance
in this case of churn we make
predictions whether this customer is
going to churn within a month we only
require like get the feedback like one
month later
um because if we now predict that he
will stay then we actually need to
observe this customer staying for like
one more month and then we actually know
if this was the right decision or not so
there is this delay in actually
calculating how well your model is
performing but it's one of the most
important things to do
what else can we do well we can monitor
the model input like all the features
that we calculate
um we can like lock them monitor them in
our system because if there's something
wrong if your model output is wrong then
probably the first question you have is
hey but what is actually going in my
model so that's like the next best thing
that you want to have if you already
have these two in place
and then if your model output is wrong
and then you see oh but my features are
also off compared to what I actually
expected or what I saw during training
then of course the last step is to also
monitor like your raw data your Source
data to see what you actually received
and where you actually
um calculate your features on this
system we're kind of flowing backwards
in monitoring priority you first want to
monitor the things that your end user or
your customer or your
stakeholder cease from your model and
you want to diagnose problems there and
then in order to like analyze what's
going wrong you go more to like to the
left to your Source data to actually
discover why certain problems occurs but
if you just have little time to
implement stuff I would start at the
right and then go left
as time progresses
all right now I have some practical
steps on how to actually implement this
because so far we've looked at this
traditional setup how can we actually
implement this if we have a second learn
model
um does not necessarily have to be a
circular model I just took that example
since it's like the most popular
framework
um in Python
so
um let's create an extra metric response
distribution to model the model outputs
that we create here you see that I made
these 10 Dockers just like 0.1 every
time to model a distribution ranging
from zero to one and we're going to add
this to our endpoints that we already
seen before
so the only line that's different is the
one highlighted here before we actually
return the prediction we are going to
observe this prediction on the response
disk metric that gets sent to this
metric endpoints that gets feed into
Prometheus
um but now we're adding like all these
monitoring steps here in this fast API
environment and it would actually be
pretty nice if we can somehow
incorporate this in this model in the
secular model
so what if we do this we have this I
could learn model it's just a simple one
it's a decision tree at the end and it
has two steps for pre-processing for the
categorical features I chose one hot
encoder and for the numerical features I
chose a simple computer to deal with the
missing values
and we can actually take these two
pre-processing components change them a
little bit to include that they can do
this monitoring for us so how does it
actually look like
if I take the one out encoder as example
I'm importing it from scikit-learn the
pre-processing module and then I'm
taking this one-off encoder I'm sort of
assuming that you've all used
scikit-learn before and you know how
like the fit transform work uh if not
please feel free feel free to ask the
questions at the end the transform step
is like it's saying like transforming
your original input to this OneNote
encoded features
we make sure to call the super.transform
to do everything that's the original uh
one of the encoder already did but now
we're adding some extra steps these
extra steps are getting the feature
names
um getting all the categories if the
categories new if we have not seen it
before which of course can be the case
in this one not encoding example then
we'll see it show up as none and then
basically we Loop through all these
categories and for each feature for each
category we increment the counter so you
get like a counter over like all the
features and all the possible categories
and also the missing ones and we just
count them to see what is actually
flowing in to the model
so that we can monitor it
then second example
same ID here we take the simple imputer
same structure we take the transform we
make sure to do the super transform
except that we also add the thing and
now we're adding
um which features are imputed with
missing values so later down the line
we're able to see
um which features are actually showing
up with a lot of missing values so that
we can make decisions about it later
all right let's actually do
a demo to show how it looks like in
practice
[Music]
um
uh all right let's start here you can
all see it right yeah
um
localhost 5000 so this is my
uh monitoring app the first API app uh
is it big enough I think so
um let's go to the predict slash random
endpoint where I just get a sample back
from a uniform distribution with some
kind of time delay on it if I just run
this
um a few times then I can see
um we got like
new accounts in if I then oh sorry
if I then go here and ask information so
this is Prometheus running at localhost
1990 if I go to this request count total
and execute it I've run it before I can
see that
um
this random endpoint has been hit like 8
000 times already
um if I like 8073 if I now hit it a few
times again
we can actually see this going up
it takes a bit of time before it gets
scraped but now we see that it has an
increase of three
um
actually instead of like manually
hitting this all the time I actually
have a script so this is where I have my
Docker composure running and here I can
just run the simulator random endpoints
and we're going to hit this endpoint in
a while through Loop
um
let's actually look at the dashboard
that I've created for this one
we go to the random endpoints I just
started the simulation
we're looking at the last five minutes
of data and we actually see that we now
have like an increase in traffic so this
is implemented I can show it for a bit
you just incremented as the request
count total I filter for which model I'm
using and then I calculate the rate over
it to get like the number of requests
per second
uh so we can see it here going up we can
see the error rate also going up I in
the simulation I included it every
sometimes it just fails so we can see
some errors
and on the right side we can see the
latency you can see like how long it
takes to process this request it has an
exponential
um simulation on that so like the high
like the bright colors are rates most
often
um how long it takes most often but of
course there's some distribution
and then here on the bottom we actually
see the distribution of the model
outputs show up it's a uniform
distribution so if we give it enough
time we'll see that it converges to this
uniform distribution
uh all from these simple metrics that I
actually showed
um
then secondly we have this other
endpoint so let me go back to this code
again and let's run this simulation for
the model
so I can simulate model here
I'm going through some production data
and just replaying these instances
and then I can switch to this decision
three and we can actually see what
happens we see that the traffic or is
already increasing since I just started
it
um we can see the latency starting we
don't see any errors yet
um because the metric doesn't show up
unless you hit it like once so when we
get the first error then we would
actually see it happening here
the way this works I promise to show
that there's this metrics endpoint
on the API
um it's not about the details so I just
want to show you that like all the
metrics are tracked here so this is what
is made available by this fast API I
have all these metrics for for me just
to scrape and then we just use it to
actually show it here
in this dashboard
one other thing that I want to show was
that we use this one hot encoder to
actually create this metric for all the
categories that we are finding in our
data so I have this model categorical
total
metric
which has feature names and categories
so if I execute this we actually like a
big list of all things that gets counted
let's make it a bit more
visible and just select like one feature
I select feature zero which is the
region feature here we can see if I
increase it a bit that we have like
different kind of regions and here we
count like how often we encounter this
region in production
which is simply filtering them here
and that's also something that we can
actually add to our to our dashboard so
below here
um what I have created we have three
categorical features so for feature zero
one and two I created this bar chart
where we can actually see like hey how
many times did we see this category and
do we observe any weird things well
weird thing I observe is that like most
of the
um
most of the API calls actually have none
as value for this region might be that
just the case that this data works this
way just recorded like this or maybe
there's something else happening it's at
least good to know that we're aware now
and then we can figure out what to do
with it later
um same thing here for this one
um
and then second Transformer that we
changed since I could learn was this
simple computer and here we can see all
the these are the categories numbers so
they don't have the name here we lost
them
good at them later but for now it's just
numbers we can see like how many missing
values are actually imputed so feature
10 and feature 9 are the ones who have
like crazy High
um number of missing values here's just
absolute counts but you can of course
also make it a ratio of like a total
number of requests
and every time like you change like your
um time frame like the dashboard updates
and recalculates like for this time
frame how many
um
how many actual accounts or ratios or
things you saw
um all right that was the live demo part
let's
continue for a little bit
um to talk about model Decay because now
we have seen a few
uh things that we can track and that we
can actually use to understand what our
model is doing but
like I said the model decays over time
like it's not
guaranteed to give you this stable
performance and it's often decaying or
getting worse over time due to Drifting
distributions
and there's basically three types of
drift that I want to introduce
first one is data drift and with Concept
drift and then we have the train surf
school which is maybe not actually a
drift but it fits this explanation so I
just include it
um data drift is the case when
um the input distributions actually
change so right from the source your
data just looks different like a lot
different or slightly different but at
least meaningful difference
um such that it is reflecting any kind
of changes in underlying data
um there's ways to actually compare
distributions there's like this KL
Divergence or there's other kind of ways
to compare them mathematically but
already from looking at the
distributions in your like production
system and looking at what you had
during training can already be
insightful before adding this complex
logic
so data drift is like inputs are
changing
now we have concept drift which is
actually the thing if the Learned
relationships in your model are no
longer true so you might have the same
input data then your model makes the
same prediction as it always did but
something changed in reality and your
model should now because of some reason
should predict something else maybe
things in society change maybe a
pandemic potatoes and a lot changed so
we need to recalibrate this model and
we're not going to find that if we just
look at input distributions we're
actually only able to find it if we can
close this feedback loop and see where
your model starts to deviate from this
ground truth
um like it says here on the slide it
needs to have wide screw in production
and from there we can actually measure
like accuracy or mean absolute error or
whatever metric you use to train your
model and to evaluate your model you can
do it in production to GIF and if you
have this data
now lastly we have this train surfing
screw which is actually the mismatch
between terrain and production phase
this can have like multiple
classes there can either be a time gap
between the moment you train then you
have like data that's maybe a few months
old you took it like a sample and then
actually when you use it for production
something changes there's like
a reason why it's not adding up and it's
basically just your trading data and not
generalizing to your current case
um
and the same way you deal with it you
compare these distributions on Metric
either as a human interpreting it or
adding like all kinds of algorithms on
it to compare these distributions and
put thresholds and put alerts on your
Prometheus system such that you get like
a notification when something is like
meaningfully different
and this thing also gives us like some
kind of notion on the question like
should we retrain
um I think it's always important for us
as the person who creates this model to
make a conscious decision about it and
not just blindly retrain and hope that
now everything is solved but at least it
gives us information to make this
decision on
all right now wrapping up uh I've told
you a lot about like the concept of
modeling machine learning in production
I've showed you some practical things
I've showed you this demo but I think
the most important thing to actually
recap is the priority of adding stuff to
your model first thing if you don't have
any monitoring please first add the
golden signals to get like an idea of
the general status of your application
is it running is it getting errors uh
what is the time that it takes for this
request to process gives you a lot of
information without actually diving into
them now
then it's about your model outputs your
model is the core thing of what you're
presenting to your user so if you model
the output you can already have some
guesses about the water something's
going wrong or not
the next bit next big step is to add
feedback can be difficult to do but will
be really really valuable to measure
actual performance of how your model is
doing and it allows you to identify
concept drift
then fourth step add your training data
into Prometheus so that you can directly
compare distributions of your features
and your Source data and like production
and training so that you can discover
this training serving SKU
and lastly add monitoring on the
distributions of your features and your
input distributions for data
availability data quality and data drift
and with these things your
in like enable yourself
um to actually find things that are
wrong in your ml system and not have
your end user come to you and say hey
like why is this not working or why did
I why do I get that results it's like
not the fastest way if you're a
stakeholder or end user has to approach
you to tell you that something is wrong
while you are making and running this
model
all right it's perfect timing
thank you
[Applause]
all right thank you very much and very
impressive timing on your talk time for
a couple questions
this one yeah
um
yeah
depends on like if you need the same
thing for every Transformer like for now
this Walnut encoder I want to do these
categories but maybe you can like
um
grab this piece out make it a separate
component and when you're dealing with
categories just add this step yeah could
be done
no I don't think so no
all right
my question is about times so you showed
us like you know a few steps setting up
Prometheus and the logging
outside
right check out the truck
um and then putting
in a truck
hello everyone
open outside so if you wanted to go and
check it out and see what a truck looks
like you're going to see it outside
with lots of Technology
right so then there's the grafana
dashboard um could you make some
comments about what takes the most time
last time I will say this
is outside thank you
foreign
Let's uh try to answer your question
um
when I've started with monitoring I
first started to create this local setup
with this like Docker compose that I
showed earlier and basically getting
like
a basic system running with this like
example project in this decision three I
got it running in like
one or two days if you want to add this
to like a more serious like production
setting you probably want to deploy this
on kubernetes and takes a little bit
more time currently I'm doing that as
support of Rotterdam and like we've
spent now like one or two weeks on it to
just like set up all the components make
sure it all works
no
all right thanks uh so you also talked
about the feedback so comparing the
predictions to the actual ground truth
yeah does
um the Prometheus supporters in some way
because you'll have to like recall your
model at some point in the future with
the same input data
um I wouldn't recall the model what I
would do is like
show more have like a database maybe SQL
maybe reddish somewhere to store your
actual predictions that you make so you
have like your when you do this post
requests with your data you want to save
like all your features you want to save
like with which model you make a
prediction and what the prediction is
and then later like a month later when
you get this information available on
the specific ID you want to add your
ground Roots then you just build
yourself a database with like all the
values the predictions and the ground
throughs and then you can expose that
information to do all kinds of queries
online confusion matrices how many
through positives do I have those kind
of things so I would keep it outside for
meters until you know everything
maybe one more
uh uh how would you monitor uh the
performance of um computer vision model
for example yeah because those are quite
hard to get yeah that's actually what
I'm currently doing so great question
um at support of Rotterdam we're doing
this computer efficient model for Asset
Management
means we have like a variety of
different models first of all we have an
object detection and segmentation model
to just identify things like lamp posts
and traffic signs and those kind of
things
um there we put counters on and you can
also like if you have a validated data
set like ious you can sort of like
calculate like how much percent of your
mouse that your model
um creates is actually also in the
ground truths to like get some idea of
uh the performance of these models of
course for like production data you
don't have to run all these masks or you
don't know it so you can just count and
see like if it makes sense the amount of
things that you detect compared to what
your inputs are
uh secondly we have a number of image
classification models running to
classify the quality of these kind of
things like traffic signs they can be
broken they can be dented they can be
like less visible we've created some
models to actually identify those and
that's just like a classification model
so the same thing that you can put on a
decision tree you can put on this
classification model because there's
just grant roots and there's predictions
all right thank you very much let's uh
give a hand for our speaker again
thank you
[Applause]
so if you want to play yourself with
this project it's available on my GitHub
I will also upload the presentation you
can basically do the entire thing
yourself and extend it
thank you
no it's not